últimos intercambios de fuego antes de
que entre en vigor La tregua en gasa
hasta las 22 hora local e incluso
algunos minutos más tarde el ejército
israelí los grupos armados palestinos
multiplicaron los ataques y los disparos
de cohetes finalmente las armas quedaron
en silencio para regocijo de la
población que por fin puede salir de sus
casas
cinco días de guerra y Batalla pero
gracias a Dios es una victoria hasta que
Alexa se ha liberado si Dios quiere
La tregua es algo bueno disminuirá la
destrucción y la demolición de casas
pero nos gustaría saber que La tregua
tiene una base sólida A diferencia de
cada vez que hay un alto el fuego y
luego un mes después hay gente que muere
un portavoz de la yihad islámica declaró
que el alto al fuego estipula que no se
apuntará a las viviendas civiles y que
no se atacará a los líderes militantes
las autoridades israelíes agradecieron a
Egipto su mediación dijeron que a la
calma se responderá con calma pero que
Israel responderá las nuevas amenazas
con lo que haya que hacer los últimos
actos de violencia estallaron el martes
cuando la Aviación israelí mató a tres
altos mandos de la hija de islámica
según las autoridades hebreas habían
planeado atentados en Israel desde
entonces se produjo un fuego cruzado más
de 30 palestinos han muerto en casa
desde el martes al menos 13 de ellos
eran civiles dos ciudadanos y israelíes
también fallecieron por cohetes lanzados
desde ga